(relaxing music)
- [Narrator] Reaching up towards the sky,
these 3,000 pillars stand
tall from the valley below
to make a towering forest of sandstone.
The Zhangjiajie National
Forest Park is located
in the west Hunan Province of China
and is over 600 miles
away from the major cities
of Shanghai and Beijing.
Fans of James Cameron's Avatar
may find these rock pillars familiar.
They were the inspiration
behind the mythical world
of Pandora in the film.
These pillars resulted from
weather over many years.
A combination of the changing seasons
and the plants that grow on them
have contributed to their
individual and unique shapes.
Although the seasons change,
the weather is moist all year round,
which results in dense foliage.
In fact, 98% of the park
is covered in vegetation.
There are hiking trails available
to see this incredible forest.
However, as James Cameron knows,
nothing compares to
experiencing it from the sky.